hey guys welcome to ask IJ it's another
fun-filled episode of answers cool
don't forget feel free to leave comments
below if you'd like me to answer your
question in the next episode our first
question comes from scoop - skipped it's
good for girls he's asking what I used
to catch my gameplay footage on my
gaming channel I just started using the
l gato HD Game Capture which uses HDMI
and I used to use the HD PVR but since
this came out it's so much easier to use
because HDMI as opposed to component mmm
big fan what's my favourite season or
month probably my favorite season is
December because I absolutely love
Christmas and I love the holiday season
could somebody please tell me why
Christmas now freakin starts in April
I'll go Walmart's what do I see
Christmas trees in April did you guys
forget about every other holiday did you
forget about you forget about Easter to
forget about Thanksgiving just get about
Halloween oh yeah actually yeah you did
merry freaking Christmas Happy Hanukkah
I read so many comments from a couple
ice-skating episodes ago where I showed
you guys my new lens on my camera the
first one says I thought that your lens
said tampon no Tampa that does not say
tampon are my feet ticklish to be
completely honest with you they aren't
and it's kind of funny because I used to
be super ticklish when I was younger but
people used to tickle torture me which I
do not think it's funny no one should be
tickled tortured because it is just that
it is torture so one day I just decided
what if I don't want to be ticklish
anymore guess what I now I'm not
ticklish anymore can you tickle my feet
please so I'm trying to show them that
I'm not ticklish you did it over here
cuz they're not gonna think that I'm
actually tickling
yeah okay sure but I wanted to get both
of them you know that's really annoying
cause I'm I'm extremely ticklish I'll
get me not to Callisto going what
started my love for Mario games I love
all video games in general but Mario
games I've always been a huge fan of it
reminds me of my childhood I grew up
playing every single Nintendo system I'm
going to show you guys my Nintendo 64
set up here in a second huzzah hey
well lil Mario shrine and get my n64
down there with a cup of Terrible Towel
represent Pittsburgh catenin 64
controller random Mario characters oh I
gotta love it if I ever had braces a
shell great teeth I did I had them for
only like a year and a half but I made
them a think of getting the clear I
thought clear braces would be really
fantastic but there was a few downsides
to that and you couldn't see that people
just thought that I had something on my
teeth all but don't I gotta find out my
face on a bill or a coin which would I
choose well I don't really know thought
my face anywhere but if I had to pick I
would probably pick the dollar or
something because I hate coin I'll end
up cashing them in it those little coin
star machines I'll put in the little
machine and magically just the real
dollar bills up here and then I take the
bills and I take them to the bank put
this in there so I can use my debit card
carrying the monies no okay so creepy
question would you rather burn to death
or freeze to death um I would probably
want it to be which everyone was quicker
because I don't really like pain let's
just hope that and then those scenarios
ever happen okay all right creepy
commenter let's find another one that's
not so depressing where's your favorite
song from the band Queen and why is this
the real life is this just fantasy in a
landslide no escape from reality and now
for the people who wanted to be in this
episode of ask IJ just a few of them
leave me a question below or just simply
say okay
I'm gonna be in the next episode I'll
see you guys then so bye